I don't want to talk a lot about this, but
I think it makes sense to say something about
it.
A few days ago, Donald Trump and people around
him have switched to calling the Corona virus
the Chinese virus.
And there was an immediate reaction from a
lot of people that's racist.
It's xenophobic.
So on and so forth.
And it may well be, but I want to give you
my take on where I am on this.
This cannot be allowed to become a distraction
from the failed slow response from the Trump
administration and actually dealing with the
virus.
I don't even care to argue about is Chinese
virus racist or isn't it?
Well, they call it the Spanish flu.
Well, but the Spanish flu is really from Kansas
and or France.
It wasn't actually from Spain.
That's a fine debate to have.
I guess maybe.
But if we allow there's a limited amount of
time in the day, there's a limited amount
of time that people are paying attention to
the news.
There's a limited amount of time that people
put effort and time into answering the question,
what do I need to do right now to help rather
than hurt with coronavirus if we allow Trump
to make the discussion about Chinese virus?
We are taking time away from the important
stuff.
He gets to control the narrative and in fact,
during yesterday's coronavirus briefing press
conference, that complete propaganda network.
Okay.
And one American use network that now has
a seat in the White House press briefing room.
This journalist in the back asked some bizarre
question about is Chinese virus really racist?
If it is, then.
Then the term Chinese food would also be racist
and Trump like the question and so on and
so forth, and was able to waste five minutes
talking about how unfairly The New York Times
treats him and CNN and all of this other stuff.
Just don't allow it.
It's idiotic.
This Chinese virus stuff is completely idiotic.
But the more we take the bait on it, the more
the attention is not on.
Why aren't we testing?
Why aren't we taste testing large asymptomatic
populations to figure out how many people
who have no symptoms are potentially super
spreaders of the disease, et cetera, et cetera,
et cetera.
So I don't even want to spend a lot of time
here.
I think, you know, a couple of minutes I just
spent is enough.
The Chinese virus stuff is crazy.
But the more we feed into it and talk about
it, the less we're talking about the more
important stuff.
So we're going to try to stay away from that
topic.
We've got a full program for you today.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter at
D Packman.
Much more coming right up.